well the rationale for creating the lane
Center for computational biology was a
lot of discussion
Stephanie and I Stephanie has a primary
interest in research in cancer I have a
primary interest in education and we
were looking for something that would
combine the two the real breakthrough
was that Carnegie Mellon is known
worldwide for its interdisciplinary
culture in the case of computational
biology and the work that we're trying
to do here in the lane Center machine
learning is important because the
complexity of the problems that we face
in biology is greater than what people
can figure out on their own the idea
therefore is to bring the power of
machine learning and the tremendous
amount of work that's been done over the
recent years especially here at Carnegie
Mellon and elsewhere to bear on one of
the most important problems that we face
which is which is how to how to do cells
and tissues and organs go wrong in
disease and how do we figure out how to
fix it the role that I see for the lain
Center is catalytic we can't as a single
Center or a single University even
contemplate building the complete models
that we need to understand how all of
biological systems work but what we can
do is to contribute tools that enable
the automated creation of such models
and so perhaps the best measure of
success of the lain Center will be in
the utilization of the tools that we
develop by people elsewhere in order to
build accurate models for particular
tissues or particular diseases
you